good evening parents of a child at the
center of a federal lawsuit against the
clark county school district are
breaking their silence
thanks for joining us here at six i'm
denise valdez and i'm christian casadas
tonight they're talking only to eight
news now
it's a story the i-team has been
following for two years now involving
allegations
that a teacher abused students the
i-team's vanessa murphy has this
exclusive interview
teacher casey glass is seen in this
surveillance video at kirk adams
elementary school in 2017 with fourth
grader hunter howard
he has autism and is non-verbal lawyers
for hunter alleged
this is abuse withholding his food as
punishment which is against the law
and taunting him i was just
shocked tamara timms and chris howard
are hunter's parents
they reached out to the i-team to speak
about this for the first time
this caught me off guard it completely
blindsided everybody in my
family they say hunter's education
started off on a positive note
he was doing well but they started to
notice changes in his behavior
especially toward his sister who he
usually bonded with
they would literally share everything
including food
and he started becoming really food
aggressive
you know and he was scratching her but
tim says she now believes hunter's
behavior was a result of what happened
in school
the i-team obtained this police body
camera video from an
interview with an alleged witness i
witnessed the teacher
with her feet roughly on top of her
student in like a kicking manner
and then i witnessed her take her hand
and push his head down towards the
ground
hunter's parents say they had to get
legal help to be able to view the video
from the clark county school district
ccsd police recommended
charges against glass the clark county
district attorney told the i-team the
case was
closed the d-a says glass was never
charged because police didn't provide
additional information his
office requested after the i-team
reached out to the department of
education
a spokesman said the allegations would
be investigated
records show glass now teaches for the
nye county school district
they all failed a federal lawsuit was
filed on behalf of hunter and another
child glass was accused
of abusing the school board approved a
1.8 million dollar settlement for both
cases
hunter's parents say their now 14 year
old son
is just not the same he's just he's so
broken so traumatized
you know even now everything about it
was wrong and should have just never
happened to begin with
shouldn't have happened to my son it
shouldn't have hap it shouldn't
happen to anybody else's child we
reached
out to the department of education a
spokeswoman says quote
the investigation is ongoing and as such
we are unable to comment and quote as
for hunter and his family
tim says they are grateful for the
person who came forward to report what
they saw in the cafeteria here
in the first place vanessa murphy 8 news
now
thank you vanessa well ccsd responded to
us saying the case
has been settled general reasons include
an assessment of potential risks and
benefits
and costs of litigation now attorneys
for casey glass
replied there is a confident
confidentiality provision
against plaintiff and plaintiff's
attorneys regarding the resolution of
the case with respect to miss glass
now the i-team also reached out to the
nye county school district which
did not respond in time for this report